you're moving into a land of both shadow
and substance of things and ideas you
just crossed over into all daint a
creepypasta our stories cook to
perfection with a splash of red sauce my
name is cz and I will be your server
this episode Anaheim 2016 amid the flash
and flair of a bustling young amusement
park at the peak of its growth the
Hollywood Tower Hotel was a star in its
own right but like all shining stars
there came a time when it would be
eclipsed by a newer franchise with the
tower on its deathbed people flocked to
go experience it before it was too late
let's dig when I heard that the Tower of
Terror at Disney's California Adventure
was being remodeled into a guardians of
the galaxy ride I immediately made plans
with my friends Joey and Matt to go pay
the ride one last visit we all decided
to take a Monday off and visit the park
on the last day of the rides operation
in hopes that there might be some kind
of special send-off if you've never been
to Disney Tower of Terror was a part
dark ride part freefall ride themed
around an abandoned Hollywood hotel
guests are told that they're entering a
special episode of The Twilight Zone
five people riding on an elevator on one
Halloween night in the 30s were struck
by lightning causing them and an entire
section of the hotel to disappear into
another dimension let me make one thing
clear I was never the type of guy who
believes in ghosts that's part of what
made me love the Tower of Terror though
the theming and effects were so well
done that you really did feel like you
were stepping into a dimension where
ghosts do exist and it was a lot of fun
as we walked through the Hollywood
Boulevard area of the park towards
Hollywood Tower I was disappointed to
see that they had already stripped off
the walls leaving behind a tower of
scaffolding where construction workers
were already at work transforming the
outside appearance of the ride as we
turn the corner to the street where the
tower was located we were met with a
huge line pouring way outside the orden
our queue area understandably it seems
like lots of other Disney fans had the
same idea that we did and wanted to give
the ride a proper send-off
we decided to hit up some of the other
rides first and return to the Tower of
Terror once the Sun had gone down this
turned out to be a great idea or so it
seemed at the time because most of the
rest of the park was relatively empty in
comparison we ended up getting on just
about everything else that we wanted to
before returning to the Tower of Terror
that evening the tower was lit with this
ominous glowing blue lights as we
approached it for the final time there
was still a very long line when we got
there which we expected so it was
getting pretty late by the time we even
hit the front gates of the attractions
official queue Joey was starting to get
nervous about us even making it in
before the park closed even though they
were open late that night we were
actually one of the last groups to go
through before they started turning
people away after welcoming us to the
Hollywood Tower Hotel a man in a bellhop
uniform with dark circles under his eyes
closed up the giant metal gates behind
us presumably never to be opened again
at first I was feeling relieved to have
made it in time to go on the ride but I
was quickly overcome with an uneasy
feeling something was off before
entering the building the line winds
through the main level terrorists
leading up to the building's entrance I
know the area is supposed to look worn
down by the elements but it looked even
shabby er than usual the plants were all
overgrown and some of the lampposts were
broken making it very difficult to see I
even came close to stepping on some
broken glass on the ground but the
strangest part was the screaming these
were no ordinary theme park screams
though they sounded like screams of
agony like someone was being tortured we
were wondering what was getting such
violent reactions out of the riders but
eventually came to find that the
screaming was coming from the speakers
hidden around the area I'm not sure if
that made me feel any better to be
honest why would they be playing such
disturbing audio for their guests
it all just seems so weird when we got
to the covered area just outside the
bill
it seemed like the pillars holding up
the structure had some considerable
decay and all the windows were broken I
couldn't remember exactly what this area
looked like last time I was here but I
was fairly certain it was at least a
little bit more put together than this
after what seemed like forever we
finally made it into the hotel this is
when things really got weird
normally the hotel lobby is made to look
like it was abandoned in the 30s which
still was only this time the room was
filled with 15 to 20 Disney employees
all wearing the same Hollywood Tower
Hotel bellhop uniform they were standing
straight up like soldiers all around the
major set pieces in the room and every
single one of them was just staring at
us it was almost as if they were
guarding something but none of them said
one word the entire time Matt even tried
asking one of the employees how much
longer would be until we reached the
front of the line to which the guy made
eye contact with him and just stared
into his soul with a completely straight
face I'll never forget the look of those
blue eyes with the dark bags underneath
piercing at us from his pale almost
grayish skin at this point I was
thinking that this all must be part of
the parks special going-away present to
the fans of the ride and they were
really going all out to make the last
night as creepy as possible
I let myself think that they were really
outdoing themselves and I was enjoying
the show I also noticed that the iconic
owl statue in the center of the lobby
was gone and it was replaced with the
sign that said the Silver Lake sisters
live at the tip-top Club only tip-top
Club was crossed out in red ink and
replaced with the word Lobby at some
point some construction workers came in
and tried to remove the sign and some of
the other furniture this was the first
time I saw one of the bellhops react and
speak up he grabbed the construction
workers hand and said sir
please the hour is not yet upon us I
assumed that this was also part of the
show I mean they wouldn't really be
clearing the place out minutes after
closure
right at this point riders are taking in
groups to the hotel library for a
briefing video Matt and Joey walked
ahead into the library but when I tried
to pass through the bellhop stopped me
and told me to wait for the next group I
tried to explain that I was with those
two guys but the bellhop wouldn't let me
pass Matt and Joey didn't seem to notice
I was gone but I figured I would catch
up with them before they boarded the
elevator when it was my turn to go see
the briefing video there were only a
couple people left in line behind me so
the three of us went in we get into the
orientation room and the lights go out
we sit there in the dark for what seems
like ages that's when I hear someone
shuffle around behind me I could swear
it was just me and those two other
guests who had come into the library I
was positive that they were the only
ones behind me in line I had to think
that whoever was behind me was just one
of the employees but then seemingly just
to disprove that theory the guy moves
closer to me and starts breathing down
my neck I was getting very uncomfortable
but then just as I was about to say
something the orientation video starts
so I just take a step forward away from
that creepy Hyneman you wouldn't want
this door with the key of imagination
behind it is another dimension dimension
of sight a dimension of sight a
dimension of mind I wasn't sure if there
was something weird going on with Rod
Serling the voice almost like it was a
pitch or something
you're moving into a land of both shadow
and substance of things and ideas just
crossed over into that's what its own
the rest of the introduction video went
on as it normally does that is until it
got to the part where rod addresses the
audience it's not the story of the
twilight zone will be your last okay now
that was definitely not normal they must
have changed up the intro video for the
final night or something this is you may
recognizes a million serfs elevator
still in operation but nothing wrong at
midnight tonight normal operation of
this machine was seized and at that
moment the stars will come out to play
when this happens you will have to fend
for yourself and your safety is not
guaranteed you are about to embark on a
ride through history in your destination
it's why it's it all right this is
exactly why we wanted to come on the
last day I was so excited I couldn't
wait to find Joey and Matt and get on
this ride the doors opened and we
continued on to the boiling the last
part of the hotel before we get into the
elevator the creep who was standing
behind me didn't join us however I
looked back and saw him just standing
there in the dark I couldn't see him
that well he was basically just a
silhouette in this lighting but I think
I made out the outline of a bellhop
uniform whatever I scan the boiler room
for my friends but I didn't see them
anywhere I hoped that they hadn't gotten
on the ride without me the more I
searched around for them the more I
realized that the entire room felt kind
of empty at least considering how many
people had just been in front of us it
was also freezing down here I was
getting goose bumps I know it was
January but we were inside it was tough
in California after all it doesn't
usually get this cold the other two guys
from the library and I were directed
past the usual Boarding stations up to
this was completely new to me I mean I
remembered seeing these stairs before
but I always thought they were just a
decoration to make the hotel feel more
fleshed out than it really is or maybe
one of those secret entrances for the
cast members to access their changing
ranks and whatnot apparently I was wrong
and there are more elevated entrances up
above as well as more pipes and
machinery and theming the only thing
that wasn't up there was people I tried
to text my friends to see where they
were at but my phone was dead from a
long day at the park one of the
employees led us to a station that was
completely empty we didn't have to wait
long for the car to arrive the elevator
shaft doors parted and we entered the
ride I chose the seat towards the middle
and the other two guys filled in on
either side of me the Tower of Terror
starts by travelling up to the first
floor where the doors open and the
guests see a mirror the narrator then
asked them to wave goodbye to the real
world
when the doors opened for our ride I saw
a man sitting directly behind me with
what appeared to be a hunting rifle this
really startled me thinking it might
have been some kind of effect like the
hitchhiking ghosts in the haunted
mansion I turned back to see that there
really was someone sitting there it was
the creepy bellhop guy again at this
point I started to freak out not only
was this the second time that this guy
inexplicably appeared behind me but he
was carrying a weapon
I know Disney can have a dark side at
times but this is still Disney we're
talking about a family company I was
getting really scared that something was
very wrong here but what could I do I
was strapped into the seat so I start to
scream and panic I don't remember
exactly what I said but I do remember
the ride violently jolting down a floor
next scene is a hallway full of guests
where writers are shown the gifts of the
five hotels from disappeared years ago
only this time the Holograms look
shockingly realistic and they don't seem
to notice us they're just standing in
the hotel talking the audio isn't that
loud but they seem to be arguing with
the employee about something and the
woman is sobbing again it was difficult
to hear over the rain and thunder but
she said something along the lines of
don't make us go she's crying begging
and pleading and the employee is just
standing there with a disgusted look on
his face before I can gather any more
information a huge flash of lightning
fills the room this may have been a
special effect but I distinctly remember
feeling the heat of this lightning
strike what I saw when the smoke cleared
completely devastated me
I saw all five of the bodies sprawled
out on the floor in a disturbingly
realistic death scene the man seemed to
have vomited all over himself and the
little girl's hair was standing up on
end but the creepiest part had to have
been her eyes which had rolled into the
back of her head her eyelids seemed to
be sparked open and it was almost as if
her blank stare was pointed right at me
I was completely at a loss for words
sounds anything when the ride jerked
upward against at the top level the ride
stopped at the top like it always does
it was dark there were only a few main
lights left on in the park I guess the
other major attractions were already
shut down
instead of the usual audio the narrator
was just laughing like a madman after a
while it went quiet and nothing happened
I was beginning to think the ride was
stuck and to be honest it was almost a
relief after everything that I had seen
the moment of solace however was
short-lived when I felt the man behind
me who I guess I had temporarily
forgotten about in all the chaos grab
onto my shoulder at this point I knew
there was nobody who could help me but I
was internally freaking out and I didn't
dare turn around and acknowledge what he
was doing now I know that people are
gonna call me out and say that I made
the story up for attention and I know
people are going to try to prove that
most of these occurrences are absolutely
impossible and I can't really blame them
for that but what I saw next even if it
was just for a fraction of a second has
stuck in my mind perfectly since that
night and I'm 100% sure of what I saw as
the ride started to drop and the man
behind me increased the pressure on my
shoulder the on ride photo camera
flashed for a split second I saw three
construction workers hanging by the neck
from the top pole upon which the camera
is mounted
these were not Holograms and even though
I only saw them for a split second I'm
quite sure that they were not props
either after that first drop the
elevator intended to bounce up and down
Ignacio and speeds between the g-force
and the pressure of the men grabbing my
shoulder I felt like I was about to pass
out I actually started to black out and
closed my eyes when I felt the ride come
to a screeching halt I was ready for
this horrific nightmare to be over but
apparently the ride had other plans once
I opened my eyes and regained my
composure I found myself on the second
floor the one with all the guest rooms
the dead bodies were still there but now
they had ghosts standing over them
motioning for us to come closer this was
actually probably the most normal thing
I had seen since getting on the right as
it resembled the scene that usually
takes place on this floor during normal
operation then to my surprise our
harnesses came off I was essentially
frozen in complete shock what the hell
was going on the creep up behind me
continued to hold my shoulder while the
other two riders got out of their seats
and casually walked through the door to
the right which to this point I wasn't
even aware was a real door I'd always
just thought it was a facade much like
the stairs in the boiler room earlier
after I'm not exactly sure how long I
snapped out of my days and realized this
was my chance to get out I rigged myself
free of the man's grasp and made a
beeline for the right side door it was a
lot I banged myself against it he didn't
budge so I darted across to the left
side door glancing at the elevator car
in passing the man in the bellhop
uniform was just sitting there giving me
this freebie sadistic grin to my
surprise the door on the left work and I
slammed it shut behind me I stumbled up
a seedy narrow staircase at the end of
which was another door I burst it
through hoping to make it to the lobby
or something but instead found myself in
an abandoned swimming pool what in the
world I mean how could this possibly
exist here I know for a fact that the
pool has never been part of the ride the
queue or any of the theming surrounding
it I vaguely remember a sign pointing to
a pool on the beginning of the line but
come on it was just a sign did I stumble
upon one of those crazy Disney secrets
like Walt Disney's New Orleans Square
apartment or the fabled basketball court
under the peak of the Matterhorn
perhaps the spool was at one time an
employee lounge of some kind all the
tiles were cracked and the pool is
filled with rust and who knows what else
there were a couple of dark objects at
the bottom of the pool I had to force
myself not to look and assume that there
were pool chairs or something but I had
a bad feeling in my gut about what they
may actually be whatever it was it
looked disgusting and I wanted to get
the hell out of there I looked around
for another exit but the first thing I
noticed was a lump across the pool my
first thought was that it was a dead
body until I saw a guy stand up and
start wobbling around like a drunk he
was wearing a hoodie and tattered jeans
my initial impression was that this was
a homeless guy who had somehow snuck in
and was living here when he saw me he
started screaming at me he kept saying
you can't take my home and cursing at me
he was clearly intoxicated as soon as I
figured out where the door was I made a
mad dash for the exit which may have in
fact been an entrance because it led me
to a dimly lit locker room I guess that
if that was one time pool for employees
that this must be the corresponding
locker room the lockers were pretty
small and most of them were open and
empty the only sound I could hear was
that of running water on the far side of
the locker room in the dark after all
that I had experienced I thought it
might be best to approach the door on
the other side of the room more
stealthily I was also feeling very sick
and needed to catch my breath I still
felt like I was going to pass out I walk
over to the source of the water keeping
my footsteps as quiet as possible
there are a few shower stalls up ahead I
poked my head into the first and it's
empty I proceeded continuing to check on
the second third and fourth stalls but
what I see in the fourth stall stops me
dead in my tracks in the corner of the
shower an old man stands in the showers
stream he's naked
senile and borderline deformed and he
has his head buried in the corner
luckily he doesn't seem to notice me so
I decided to tiptoe past him to get to
the door I make it across safely but as
I gripped the door handle I hear a
terrifying cry out from behind me I see
you you'll never get me out of here
you're the one who has to go
I hear wet footsteps charging out of a
shower stall behind me and wastes no
time yanking the door open and fumbling
my way through the next room in the dark
this leads me back to the original
mirror room the elevator car from the
ride is now there seemingly just waiting
for me the creepy bellhop guy is in the
same seat continuing to stare me down I
don't even bother to stop running across
the mirror room through the door on the
other side now I'm in another hotel
corridor but different from the one
upstairs at the end of the hall I see a
woman and yet another bellhop character
this one wearing a red pair of Mickey
Mouse ears with an Iron Man logo on it
the two were having a dispute she's
screaming and grabbing onto the sides of
the doorframe as he violently tries to
pull her out of the room she's screaming
please don't make me go and he would
just methodically respond by telling her
that her stay is up and she's welcome to
check into one of their other hotels he
then yanked her hard enough for her to
lose grip on the door and she flew
across the hallway crashing her head on
the wall hard enough to draw blood she
collapsed on the floor in front of him
that's when he looked up and noticed me
with the same intense stare that the
bellhops down in the lobby
given us my vision was starting to get
blurry so I decided to go into one of
the rooms to see if I could buy myself
some time I assumed that all the doors
were fakes but was pleasantly surprised
when one of them actually opened leading
to yet another corridor I was too tired
to try to comprehend how this was
possible given the layout of the ride
and given the fact that these secret
rooms have no reason to exist in the
first place just then the room went dark
and the walls floor and ceiling became
projection map with the starry night sky
the same effect used in the second floor
of the actual version of the ride at the
end was a single door I took this is the
metaphorical exit to the twilight zone
so I ran to it as fast as I could as I
was running I heard the narrator's
booming voice one last time next time
you try to mess with history make sure
you know just what kind of things you're
filling or you may find a few nasty
surprises coming your way you may or may
not have made it through tonight but to
close this door is to forever live on in
your head in Twilight Zone and just like
that it was over the sound of the thirty
soundtrack played in my ears and I was
making my way down the stairs trying to
think about if Joey and Matt had a
similar experience to what I had and
what happened to those two strangers
what if I was the only one to make it
out who would believe me a light caught
my eye the ride photo at the top of the
drop the guy was grabbing on my shoulder
not to mention the hanging bodies that
would also probably be in frame I ran up
to the preview screen if I needed proof
this would be it but when I looked at
the photo it was just me and two other
guys no creepy bellhop no bodies just a
regular ride photo the gift shop was
completely devoid of any gifts or people
so feeling defeated I passed through and
met up with my friends as I had feared
they made no mention of anything
abnormal and asked if I was okay a
regular Disney employee in a yellow
button-down shirt informs us that the
park is closing and to make our way to
the exits we walk out of the park I
turned back to see the lights coming
down in the Tower of Terror one last
time there are already cranes in place
ready to start ripping pieces off the
sure other than that though it looks
completely normal from the outside no
hanging bodies at the top nothing out of
the ordinary before turning back I see a
window open on one of the floors new to
the top I stopped walking Joey asked
what's gotten into me as I stare back at
the ride for the final time a light
shines out the window and the silhouette
of a bellhop sticks his head out and
waves at me I don't plan on going back
to write the new guardians of the galaxy
right when it opens I believe in ghosts
[Music]
thanks for listening to all dente
creepypasta your total comes out to
nineteen dollars and thirty nine cents
but if you like this video right now
I'll waive that fee and give you
everything you just listen to absolutely
free remember to subscribe to seize
these worlds for new Horrors every other
week and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we survive
[Music]